hire your best friends and family I have
a very different point of view like
that's such a common thing right like
don't hire friends and family I think
it's the complete reverse the first five
employees is everything hire friends and
family and then try to turn everybody
else into friends and family right like
like everybody in my life makes fun of
me that I only have my only friends are
like my employees like I can't help it
like I don't know like it is what it is
so I think um it'd be very human with
them be vulnerable be transparent be
candorous try to teach too many people
have too much of their self-esteem
wrapped up in them being the best at
their thing when they hire employees it
completely [ __ ] them up the biggest
reason people don't grow teams is
because of ego like maybe the first
person won't be right but you can't
worry about who you're gonna hire before
you hire them
meaning like you know what's gonna
happen they're gonna You're Gonna Lose
the client okay but if you don't grow
you won't grow thank you you're welcome
thanks
[Music]